danse dodo tricot la soirée a été longue
très longue puis le dénouement en
souhaité est survenu aux aurores en
seulement quelques minutes
le président de la coque 15 a proposé
l'adoption du cadre mondial pour la
protection de la biodiversité une
proposition immédiatement appuyée par le
Mexique
un texte parfait ça n'existe pas la
perfection et l'ennemi du bien lance la
délégué donc
quelques pays africains ont voulu
exprimer leurs mécontentement je suis
obligé de vous dire que les consignes
qui étaient les miennes au départ de ma
capitale sont bafoués et je voudrais
exprimer ma déception le président a
entendu les doléances et a jugé que le
consensus était atteint
le cadre mondial communique Montréal est
donc adopté un cadre que plusieurs
qualifies d'historiques on a finalement
le moment Paris pour la biodiversité ici
à Montréal et on a maintenant l'entente
le cadre mondial pour la biodiversité
coup de Montréal c'est un moment
vraiment historique il y a la fois des
références au pesticides on évacue pas
la question des subventions qui sont
nocives pour pour la biodiversité il y a
des engagements qui sont précis avec
avec des dates l'objectif phare de
protection de 30% des terres et des
Océans étantchassés dans le texte tout
comme l'obligation de réduire de moitié
les risques liés aux pesticides et
l'accord avalise aussi la création d'un
fond dédié à la biodiversité tels que
souhaitée par les pays en développement
équilibré emprunt de compromis et
parfois fragile oui Fink that stronger
il faut le dire la corporalité un succès
aussi et surtout grâce à la
collaboration exemplaire entre la Chine
et le Canada un jeu d'équilibriste dans
le contexte géopolitique actuel ici et
les acérées au Canada Montréal